hello peanut he's looking at you and
we're looking at you happy birthday to
the birthday boy it's been so much fun
to be on this journey the kardashians
celebrate saint west turning six jesus
although his mom kim kardashian admits i
try to not
give them lots of gifts for their
birthday i'm like the anti she sure did
show her second born a ton of love with
the birthday tribute on instagram the
mama 4 posted a collage of photos of the
little one writing quote my baby saint
is six today there is no one like you
and your smile and your negotiating
skills i've never met anyone that takes
roblox as serious as you thank you for
being my bestie with the best snuggles
you woke up today and promised me that
you will snuggle with me until you're
10. i love you forever
every day he has to give kisses and hugs
kim's sister courtney gave a sneak peek
into saints birthday bash on her insta
story which included a huge slide
on his big day saints he also received a
sweet birthday shout out from his
grandma kris jenner and he's such a
blessing so it's perfect she shared a
heartfelt message alongside a number of
adorable photos of saint with her his
siblings and his dad on instagram in her
caption chris praised saint for being
quote such a good brother such a good
cousin such a good son and such an
amazing grandson
adding quote you are so kind and so
gentle and so loving i'm so proud of you
and i love you more than you can ever
imagine i thank god for you every day
and for the blessing of having you as my
grandson
happy birthday my little angel i love
you love you love you
speaking of angels kim took these six
rainbows she randomly found in her house
as a sign of her father the late robert
kardashian telling his grandson happy
birthday on her insta story she shared a
photo of the sixth and final rainbow and
wrote quote omg a six rainbow for my
saints sixth birthday i've never had
this many rainbows in the same room at
once thanks dad i'll tell saint you said
happy birthday hashtag needed this you
think tom brady could throw it that far
ah come on
no he only missed that because he had
[Music]
when it comes to saints dad kanye west
he wiped his instagram account clean in
the wake of the passing of his friend
designer virgil abloh but last month the
proud father posted a black and white
video of saint playing catch with
football legend tom brady and what
appears to be a private box
as they were tossing the football back
and forth saint made sure to let the
super bowl champ know he's
multi-talented just like his dad who
captioned the clip quote tom and saint
the home team wins
i hope that they
just find their own motivation back in
2018 kim opened up to e.t about what she
hopes her children take away from her
and kanye as they continue to get older
no matter what that is no matter what
they want to do in life i hope that they
work really hard i think they have good
examples i learned from seeing both of
my parents work really hard
and i think our kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path they think
to not
pressure but to definitely have our our
rules
is the best that you can do
[Music]